hey you know Pablo Escobar the drug lord
yeah I'm at his old house right now here
in rural Colombia and I'm looking for
some hippos oh wait no no no hippos
aren't supposed to be here
they're never they're not supposed to be
hippos exist here not in Colombia the
Pablo Escobar was one of the most
infamous and most successful drug lords
in history the guy had an entire empire
of cocaine production and trafficking
throughout the world one of the world's
most wanted men drug trafficker Pablo
Escobar is also accused of murder and
terrorism and with all of his drug money
he wanted to build a private Zoo he
imported giraffes and exotic animals
from all over the world including four
hippos and Pablo Escobar was shot and
killed in the early 90s the government
came in and reclaimed this estate and
they took all the animals and they
distributed them out to other zoos
except with the hippopotamuses they
didn't touch the hippos they kind of
just let them go free into the swamp
these hippos are now a ticking time bomb
[Music]
[Music]
today there are 50 of these hippos they
proliferated very quickly and they are
now a big problem for the Colombian
government and a threat to these locals
to understand why this is such a big
deal you have to understand hippos
hippos are huge mammals native to the
continent of Africa and they're pretty
aggressive some call hippos the most
ferocious mammals on the planet
[Music]
wait there's that one scene in Fantasia
where the hippos are dancing ballet with
the crocodiles and it's the crocodiles
that seem scary not the hippos well the
reality is actually the exact opposite
hippos routinely kill crocodile
more people are killed by hippos in
Africa every year than any other wild
animal escobar's estate has since been
turned into a theme park where you can
kind of wander around and look at
different animals and the hippopotamuses
then became kind of a part of the
spectacle it's actually a pretty cool
park like if I were staying here a few
days I would totally hang out here
so the audio track that the plane that's
explaining these hippopotamuses frames
them as this positive experiment in
Conservation Park a Sipapu solo das
plant a biscotti conservación de éstos
acidosis animal cell batteries that
they're able to live in a natural
environment and to thrive this unit but
I'm gonna go talk to a biologist who
actually has a very different take so
the problem here is that the park can't
actually contain the hippos they've
actually started wandering and settling
down in rivers and ponds hundreds of
miles away we're coming up to another
group here there's just three of them
that hang out in this other pond hope so
dahveed and his team are tasked with
figuring out a solution to this problem
of how to stop these hippos from moving
around and what to do with the
population as it grows but this is
really hard stuff mainly because no
one's ever had to do this before
here's why this is a big problem what
you're looking at here is what David
calls yes this is simple heaven in
Africa there's usually droughts at stave
off the proliferation of the hippos here
there aren't droughts without a natural
predator or any sort of competition
they're sexually active earlier on in
their lives they eat more
they are just living their best lives in
total because every man thought they
thought about him Columbia is one of the
most biodiverse places on earth and a
growing invasive species population
means a disruption to that diversity
invasive species are a top cause for a
loss in biodiversity and biologists have
already started to notice that the
hippos presence is reshaping these
ecosystems but it's not just a threat to
the ecosystems sometimes the hippos will
come into town
Pasi Elena's own eccentric attend a
local EDA as the HIPAA population
spreads they're coming in contact with
humans more often and dangerous so far
no one's gotten hurt in one of these
encounters but with the HIPAA population
growing so quickly it won't be long
before an accident happens so the beat
and his team have come up with a few
strategies to tackle this problem first
they tried to physically contain them
with fences and rock walls
[Music]
[Music]
okay so fences don't work next they
tried to castrate the male's stop them
from reproducing but tranquilizing and
castrating a hippo is dangerous
time-consuming and expensive so one
solution is what you do to any big
dangerous invasive species when they
start to take over an ecosystem that
they're not native to you exterminate
them
[Music]
this didn't go well the hunting team
went out killed one of the hippos and
then they posted this photo which
sparked a national outcry people did not
like the idea hunted and killed this
much basically ain't a week a mighty
move on mass spect or not shown here not
the best solution and when the vide is
really pushing for is to just move these
hippos away misty on our economy is a
torment of fantasy killers pause but
until that happens Pablo Escobar's
oldest state will keep selling tickets
to people who want to see the hippos de
vida and his team will continue to
struggle to contain the situation and
the hippos the real winners in all of
this will continue to bask in the
reality that they truly do live in Ipoh
heaven
you
[Music]